[Musique]
alma c'est le d'une trilogie enfin c'est
les deux premier volume d'une trilogie
dont le deuxième tome vient de paraître
par romande aventure normand qui
témoigne aussi de ces années
tragiques qui ont été ces trois ou
quatre cents ans de la traite des
esclaves
[Musique]
il se trouve que ce deuxième volume
se termine c'est et dernier chapitre se
passe autour de versailles du château
c'est un moment clé de mon histoire donc
ça a tellement de sens à la fois ce lieu
en particulier et puis ce festival où on
parle d'histoire
[Musique]
on a très envie toujours de rencontrer
ses lecteurs parce qu'il ya eu dans le
métier d'auteur une un côté solitaire et
donc oui effectivement une grande joie à
se retrouver devant ses lecteurs pouvoir
les rencontrer à voir le retour de ce
qui est
fait dans cette solitude de l'écriture